- ♪ ONE AT A TIME ♪
♪ I PUT MEN LIKE YOU
BEHIND BARS EVERY DAY ♪
♪ ONE AT A TIME ♪
- ♪ LEGATEAUX,
YOU MAY TAKE MY YEARS ♪
♪ BUT CANNOT LOCK
MY SOUL AWAY ♪
♪ ALL THE YEARS
I HAD TO RUN ♪
- ♪ I CHASED YOU
THROUGH THE YEARS ♪
- ♪ SO LONG AGO IT ALL BEGUN ♪
- ♪ NOW YOUR JOURNEY'S
AT AN END ♪
- ♪ IN THE SHADOWS
ON MY SHAME ♪
- ♪ YOU WILL PAY
FOR WHAT YOU'VE DONE ♪
- ♪ BUT WAS I EVER TO BLAME? ♪
- ♪ DEATH WILL BE
YOUR ONLY FRIEND ♪
- ♪ DO I LET
THIS FIGHT END NOW? ♪
- ♪ DO NOT INTERRUPT ME ♪
- ♪ JUST TO END
THIS LIFE OF PAIN ♪
- ♪ LET ME FINISH
WHAT I NEED TO SAY ♪
- ♪ WILL THE END
BE WELCOME NOW? ♪
- ♪ FINE, I'LL LET YOU
FINISH FIRST ♪
- ♪ WILL MY JOURNEY
BE IN VAIN? ♪
- ♪ DON'T LET ME
GET IN YOUR WAY ♪
- ♪ I ONLY STOLE
A LOAF OF BREAD ♪
- ♪ ARE YOU FINISHED NOW? ♪
- ♪ ALL I NEEDED ♪
♪ TO SURVIVE ♪
- ♪ OKAY, NOW IT'S MY TURN ♪
- ♪ IF I END UP
IN YOUR CELL ♪
- ♪ CAN WE HAVE
SOME GIVE AND TAKE? ♪
- ♪ WHY SHOULD I HAVE
STAYED ALIVE? ♪
- ♪ LET ME GET A WORD,
AT LEAST ♪
- ♪ DO I TELL HIM
THAT I LOVE HIM ♪
♪ DO I TELL HIM
OF HIS CHILD ♪
- ♪ NOW, WHERE DID THIS BITCH
COME FROM ♪
- ♪ I HAVE NO IDEA ♪
- ♪ ONE AT A TIME ♪
- ♪ WILL HE EVER KNOW
HIS DAUGHTER? ♪
- ♪ LADY, SERIOUSLY,
PLEASE HANG ON ♪
- ♪ WILL HE RECOGNIZE
HER EYES? ♪
- ♪ IT'S HARD ENOUGH
TO TALK TO HIM ♪
- ♪ DID YOU SAY MY DAUGHTER? ♪
- ♪ YOURS AND MINE ♪
- ♪ ONE AT A TIME ♪
all: ♪ THE TRUMPETS
CALL OUT FREEDOM ♪
- ♪ THIS ALL HAS TO HAPPEN
ON THE SAME BLOCK? ♪
all: ♪ LET THE MARCHING
SHAKE THE GROUND ♪
- ♪ NOW THIS IS JUST A JOKE ♪
♪ WE COULD SOLVE ALL THESE
ISSUES IF EVERYONE JUST SPOKE ♪
♪ ONE AT A TIME ♪
- ♪ TAKING WHAT WE CAN, 'CAUSE
THINGS ARE GETTING WORSE ♪
♪ TAKING WHAT WE CAN
FROM EVERY POCKET AND PURSE ♪
- ♪ ONE AT A TIME ♪
- ♪ THE MEN HAVE COME ♪
all: ♪ THEIR BLOOD
WILL SPILL ♪
- ♪ ONE AT TIME ♪
- ♪ THE YEARS
DESTROYED THE MAN ♪
♪ SHE KNEW
BEFORE WE PARTED ♪
all: ♪ AND WHEN LOVE AND WAR
AND BLOOD AND GLORY'S ♪
♪ BARRACKS
HAVE BEEN CLIMBED ♪
♪ WE WILL DIE ♪
- ♪ I WILL LOVE ♪
- ♪ YEARS, THEY PASS ♪
- CAN'T WE SPEAK?
all: ♪ ONE ♪
both: ♪ HERE WE GO AGAIN,
POPPING IN AND OUT ♪
♪ DON'T HAVE MUCH TO DO
WITH WHAT THIS IS ABOUT ♪
all: ♪ A TIME ♪
- ♪ WHY ARE WE ALL
FACING THE SAME WAY? ♪
- IS THE CITY ON FIRE?
WHAT'S WITH ALL THE SMOKE?
OH, NOW WE'RE ALL EARS.
GREAT.
[grand orchestral music]